this podcast and every other podcast I
make is supported by patreon if you want
to throw the patreon a dollar you'd be
helping to support these relatively nice
shows that I intend to be very
educational and informative about the
games industry talking to a lot of very
cool people but there are other
memberships that include some special
bonuses too such as completely unedited
q and A's ad free versions of content
unedited versions of shows and even the
ability to play games with me so if you
want to support some independent games
industry podcasts check out the link in
the description Hello everyone I'm Alana
and welcome to another episode of video
game writing 101 this is Josh Sawyer uh
Josh for anyone who doesn't know you who
are you and what do you do
I am the studio design director at
Obsidian Entertainment and I was the
director on pentiment and before that
many many years ago I started at black
Isle Studios where I worked on icewind
Dale one and two uh after that I was at
obsidian where I worked on Neverwinter
Nights 2 and I directed Fallout New
Vegas and pillars of Eternity one and
two you say your actual uh title at the
studio again I'm the studio design
director what does that mean exactly
well
it's um I'm basically the advisor with
uh all the other teams with anything
that relates to design so I'm not like
the king of design but at any point
where my opinion is requested or desired
I will give my opinion and feedback on
anything from hiring processes the tests
that we administer uh to writing
standards or a system design whatever is
necessary uh so yeah I advise the other
teams on design matters but I spend most
of my day today doing uh directing my
own games yeah so recently obviously
pentabint came out yes congratulations
it's awesome and seems to have been very
well received in reviews thank you yes
I'm very happy what were you expecting
the reception to be it's such a unique
game did you have any idea how it was
going to do critically
you know
um it would be I would be lying to say I
had no idea but um I've been doing this
a while and so I have a general sense
and with this game I had a general sense
that
some people were going to really really
really love it and some other proportion
of people were not going to like it at
all
and it's it's with a game like New Vegas
I have a better idea of like I think
most people are going to think this is
fine
um wait that's what you thought of New
Vegas
when it came out yeah wow that's funny
with with uh if you look back at the
history of it it was not that well
received when it came out but um anywho
pentiment
um there was a stronger sense I had that
there were some people who played it who
were like I love this this is exactly
the game I want to play I love this and
then there are other people who are like
this is not really my thing either
they're like I don't like narrative
games I don't like games with no Vo
um I just like different types of games
whatever it was or like I think your
writing stinks whatever it was like
there were some people who say that no I
didn't see people say that I'd be very
surprised but um you know it's it's
always a possibility so I guess the
thing is going into it I was not sure
what the proportion was going to be I
thought that maybe it would be like 30
of reviewers are like this is awesome
and then 70 are like no thank you
um so yeah I was pretty pretty pleased
um you know there are people who are
reviewers at least and certainly
obviously Gamers who uh don't
fundamentally like the game or think
that the execution was off and that's
totally fair but for the people that
loved it
great love it they'll take it yeah
exactly
um so for anyone who's watching who
maybe doesn't know what exactly is
pentiment how do you describe it well
the very simple version is Night in the
Woods meets name of the Rose that's
really good and it uh it really was
inspired by both of those things very
heavily but in in more detail it is a
narrative Adventure game and it's set in
16th century Bavaria which is part of
the Holy Roman Empire what we would
today call Germany
and you play an artist a journeyman
artist named Andreas Mahler and you are
a professional artist ending their uh
Vander Yara their wandering years where
they study and work at different places
before becoming a master and he spends
his last few months working at a
Benedictine Abbey called kirso and while
he is working there he befriends uh an
older monk who is a painter named
brother Piero and unfortunately during
his time there there was a murder of an
important nobleman and the Abbott blames
Piero for the murder even though it's
pretty obvious that he couldn't have
done it and Andreas is like well I am
going to set out to prove that somebody
else did it and that starts a series of
Investigations and murders that take
place over 25 years during which time
Andreas and tassing and kirsaw change a
whole bunch
so when it came to writing this game did
you already have the um the knowledge of
all of the the history is this something
that you're already interested in I
downloaded every piece of historical
data into my brain no um when it comes
to writing something like this and for
any of the writers on the team like
where do they start with it I mean it
feels very historically accurate
actually yeah thank you
um yeah so I I mean I I have a degree in
history
um yeah I went to school uh well I went
to school for music and then switched
and then I yeah exactly many people many
such cases and um I got a degree in
history focusing on the Holy Roman
Empire in the early modern period so
15th 16th century and uh that always
kind of stayed with me and I maintained
an interest in it like a lot of the
books that I still read I don't read
that much fiction I usually will just
get history books about things that I
think are interesting and um so I did
have some information coming into it but
um I did a lot more research while
working on the game both scholarly
articles and historical manuscripts and
history books
and we had three historical Consultants
that we worked with as well so um three
phds who are all experts in their fields
and uh anytime I reached the the end of
my academic rope I would just
please tell me tell me what am I missing
like is there a source that I can look
at is there something I can see that can
help me out of this and they always came
through so it was great when you're
preparing that information to give to a
team in an easily digestible way
what does that look like did you have
somebody who was making a bunch of
documents about certain historical
figures and places like wow
yeah it's um I think you have to be
careful because the thing is uh as a as
a director or in my case a director
who's also the head of the writing team
um you can't just dump a million gallons
of information on people and expect them
to absorb that I've learned is that
people uh won't read the things you
write which as a write-up is a bit of a
Bubba yes so the thing what I try what I
always try to do is play to the
strengths of the people that are on my
writing team so in this case
um over the course of the project we had
a total of four writers including myself
at any given time we had two or three
total just because of people moving
around and doing other things so a high
degree of mentorship helped a lot
because I was able to just give the
direct feedback about like this
historical thing or that historical
thing
um there were some things that were
easier than others so for example Kate
dollar Hyde who I just is an incredible
writer and I was so happy I got to work
with her again on this project but she
doesn't really have much historical not
knowledge and I focused her on the
peasantry largely because the peasants
also don't have they're not like super
educated they don't have all the
sophistication of the monastic people or
the University students and things like
that so um for her I wanted I wanted her
to
um draw a wider variety of characters
that were more grounded in their
material reality that is we're starving
or we're being taxed or whatever and I
gave her that historical context
um which is not only very important to
the time period but it's very important
to the actual story that's going on it
is it is about these people kind of
suffering and and right your first
conflict is hey we need more money yeah
we need more money yes very right away
so um so yeah I gave her all that
context and worked with her on that and
then we also had another writer on the
staff who was
um a medievalist and she uh actually
taught Latin and so she she she did a
lot of like the Latin documentation and
wrote some of the more like educated
characters
um and that was Zoe France Nick and then
Merton radicep
um he lives in Europe and works in
Europe and so he could bring some of his
expertise about just the actual
landscape because the rest of us are
just Americans
um and so I just try to play to the
strengths of the writers and also what
they show an interest in writing because
if they show an interest in it they're
probably going to do a little bit of
digging on their own and of course if
anyone asks me for sources I can give it
to them or or find out so there would be
cases where Kate or I or Zoe or Martin
would kind of go like I don't
what would be happening here and we'd
either I'd I'd rather do the research or
I would ask one of the consultants and
then I would pass on the information to
the writer so
um so I thought you were doing all of it
at once it was uh oh no no no a process
of I actually write his rooms of then
being like what is this who do we need
to ask a question to and then exactly
okay yeah that makes a lot more sense
then
and uh and a lot of the um a lot of the
groundwork for both the story although I
worked a lot with Kate to actually
because she's much better at plotting
than I am it's it's a weakness of mine
so I leaned very heavily on her to help
me figure out plot points and pacing
um but in terms of the characters in the
cast because I do have a pretty solid
understanding of the period I designed
all and like I created the the town
itself and the Abbey itself and the
characters so I wasn't asking the
writers to kind of create a historical
figure out of nothing I did all the
research and and consultation with uh
people to actually get the foundation of
that so by the time a character went to
someone we had a working idea of who
they were the context that they lived in
their relationships to the people around
them and I think that took a lot of the
um
kind of the difficulty out of like like
what does a person do or like how do
they how do they sound and then whenever
we ran into a conflict where we're like
how do we represent this uh you know
we'd stop and we'd hash it out and
sometimes we'd have to go back and do
some revisions but I think for the most
part it was a pretty good process were
you uh sorry were these writers that
were already at obsidian or did you hire
specifically for this game looking for
people who had interest in for the
writing again specifically
um who had interest in in of the
historical context
um K dollar hide is I've been working
with her since dead fire and I just like
working with her so I was like I want
her to be my writing partner and that
was the initial intention she wound up
moving over to another project because
she had an opportunity
um and so then we hired uh from outside
and I looked for someone who was uh had
more expertise in the area of the
historical period and things like that
and uh and yeah and then just good
writers so you know it's one of those
things where obviously being more
familiar with languages the historical
context that's helpful but not if you
can't translate it you still got to be a
good writer so
um you know that that was sort of the
bottom line it's just I lucked out with
Zoe especially that um that she was so
um
versed in this stuff and also actually
Merton just in his own academic
background had some training that that
was helpful as well so it just worked
out very well that um although that's
not that uncommon in my experience to
wind up working with a writer who when
you they're like yes I have a degree in
Psychology or anthropology or history or
something it's sometimes it's it's
English and and writing strictly but um
I found a lot of humanities Majors kind
of spread out throughout the
you said you you uh you swapped your
degree yeah mine was psychology first
writing very good which is actually
really help helpful for a lot of
character work to be honestly I would
imagine that I like to use in the
psychology that I was studying that is
actually very helpful like even building
a character bio or something like that
of course would be very helpful I guess
everything is when it comes to to
writing having any different background
other than writing is extremely helpful
ah liberal arts yes we do what we can
yes so in terms of you you mentioned you
know you would come up with the town and
the characters I want to ask because I
feel like this is just such a unique
game especially in the Triple A Space
did you have to pitch this game or was
this something that you were approached
to pitch especially considering you're a
director at the studio how did actually
you know having the discussion of it
being approved
come about
well uh around the time I had some ideas
for this game around the time dead fire
shipped
excuse me and I was uh I was pretty
burned out after dead fire
and I wasn't sure I wasn't sure I was
ready to direct I was I took a break for
a while and I had this idea for a game
but I was like I don't I don't know how
we would do this it's probably like a
dozen person team
and I don't think a publisher is going
to want to fund this it's me asking yeah
and I was like and and then like
crowdfunding maybe but I don't know and
so I was pretty I wasn't kind of in the
slumps for a while and I started to kind
of pull out of that around the time that
Microsoft uh acquired obsidian and they
have Game Pass and I thought
perhaps this would be an ideal Game Pass
game and so that's how I pitched it so I
went to my boss and I said let me make
this I'll it'll be a very small team and
I won't lose money and it'll be a good
fit for Game Pass it'll be cool
um but I said you know I will keep it
small I'll keep the scope really
controlled and uh he said sure go for it
and um I started with just my art
director Hannah Kennedy and the two of
us worked for a little while then we had
a five-person team do a prototype and
then eventually we grew to the final
team which was 13 people how long did
you work on it for
I guess
um I want to say like nine months to a
year in pre-production and then about
two years in uh actual production gotcha
and I guess how much of that was uh was
writing like would you consider that
just the actual production part yeah I
mean we I was doing although we threw
out all of our writing in um after
vertical slice because as you do you do
um so yeah production it was pretty much
the entire period of production and
uh you know for quite a while for a
while it was literally just me and then
it was Kate and I and uh and then she
transferred off and everything but like
I said it was usually two writers
sometimes three
um
and yeah we use our proprietary internal
tool set oei tools which we've been
using since 2006 and it's a visual
flowchart editor it's very powerful uh I
love it it's my favorite tool and um let
a lot of Studios say that so no yeah
exactly yeah novice writing tools are a
mess if if there are tools
um
so yeah and I mean for us doing
branching dialogue our tool is like
really key to that and um yeah in the
end we wrote uh uh I think it wound up
being just shy of 350 000 words of I was
gonna ask not entirely dialogue that's
350 000 words of text including like the
glossary and glossary and yeah all the
UI strings and all that stuff so I want
to say it's probably like
I think it was like 30 000 lines of
dialogue a lot of dialogue yeah which
but it's crazy because for an obsidian
game it's actually that's what I was
gonna say it was like for obsidian it's
not that much really no yeah scheme of
things it's pretty on brand I I think
it's enough for the game though so I'm
not I'm not I'm not sad that we only had
350 no no it's the the writing is is so
good thank you very much yeah I'm such a
fan it's it's just so smart it comes
across like so so um well directed I
would say is that it's very clear that
the vision's really consistent and yeah
it's a big fan um so you mentioned a
vertical slice and I want to ask this
because I try to be uh informative on
this podcast that's the plan and I don't
think anyone's ever mentioned a vertical
slice before
um I guess what is that and what does it
do
so ostensibly a vertical slice is done
to kind of prove out the things that
you're trying to do both from an
experiential perspective and also to
prove out your pipelines so there are
really two different types of goals the
experiential one is hopefully
self-evident this is the experience that
we're trying to create for the players
so you want to do things in the way to
create the experience that you want the
player to have so you sh you know and
and maybe you got to squint a little bit
and kind of you know like okay that's
not quite there that's not quite there
but people should have confidence when
they see the final thing I get what
they're trying to do and I think it's
going to work for Their audience and not
all audiences are the same so you do
have to consider who the audience is and
then the second part is testing out
pipelines you want to establish the way
by which you actually do things on the
game and you do this in pre-production
in a a small team environment so that
you're not burning money
um you know you have five people who are
really key to each department are in our
case it was five I'm pre-production on a
big project could be you know 30 people
potentially but proportionally it's a
small team because you want to have
everyone as close to like seeing through
the same eye as you possibly can like we
all understand what we're trying to
accomplish we all are trying to figure
out the ways in which to do it and when
we're done we're all coming out of this
with high confidence that
we're doing it the way we want to do it
um we're giving the player what we want
to give them and we're our pipelines the
way in which we're doing things are
solid not to say completely done because
that I don't think is realistic you
always find work and you always do
things but
you can't be too wishy-washy about it
you really have to make sure that people
are truly confident in what you're doing
both because that enthusiasm is going to
and confidence is going to carry them
forward
um and also it's going to stop them from
getting frustrated because they're like
we have a pipeline it works instead of
instead of saying go into production
staff up and you're just constantly
tripping over each other because you're
like God we never figured out how to
import Bo oh my god
um or like oh we never figured out the
cutscene import like whatever that was
um so yeah the vertical slice is it's
it's both for the team and for external
shareholders in our case it was um you
know the upper management at obsidian
and then also Xbox because we had to
show to Xbox and say like by the way
we're making this game
um and then they said awesome but you
know the the healthy way to handle a
vertical slice is if you don't land you
stop and you fix those things before
Staffing up that doesn't always happen
but that's the way it should work is
that you know you get to the end and you
go like you know what like
the way that we present these dialogue
checks it just it's confusing it's it's
pretty it's pretty bad and it seems like
a fundamental problem like we have to
address this before we move on so we got
to revise it look at it again in context
and then we all got to go like yeah
that's it and move on or we never did
anything with the audio pipeline like
it's a completely immature pipeline we
have to take a step back do the effort
to get audio in and you know you can
contextualize and say like okay this
isn't final audio but it does test the
pipeline all the data all the everything
the tuning the placement everything
again so that you say at the end of it
okay now now we're all confident we're
not pushing this under the rug we feel
good about how we're doing things and
we're going to move forward this way and
that also applies to writing finding
character voice
um you know establishing the cast of
characters like can we can we write this
many characters
if we can write this many characters how
many nodes can we write per character
per day for each person so there are
Logistics there that helps you Scope the
rest of the game because if you say
we're going to write in vertical slice
we're going to write
20 000 lines of dialogue and you finish
and it's 10 000 lines of dialogue and
everyone says the dialogue isn't very
good like my conversations are really
short I don't really feel like I have a
clear sense of voice of these characters
motivations are kind of lacking that's a
problem so what do you do are you going
to staff up are you going to scope down
like are you going to extend the time
out what's what's what's the solution
the important thing at that at that
point between pre-production and
production is to answer those questions
without bullshitting each other because
that's where you get into real trouble
yeah uh how long was your vertical slice
out of curiosity I think it was nine
months okay I think it was like nine
months maybe as long as a year maybe 11
months I'm kind of guessing but it's
that that sounds about right who knows I
you know I've had I've had vertical
slices that are way too short and were
absolutely not done and we just roll
right out of them and it's bad yeah
um our vertical slice felt like a
miniature version of our Act One
impediment and it was pretty good
everyone was kind of like yeah and there
were things that we changed but um yeah
so why did you throw things out
um excuse me
because we learn through the process of
making and you kind of like look back
and you just see this kind of ossified
pile of [ __ ]
and you don't like you don't want to
carry that into the game and and I did
something intentionally which was I
constructed a a throwaway narrative
which was about brother gee being
murdered brother gee is not murdered
spoilers
um but he is a character in act one and
within the context of the vertical slice
the murder mystery was about brother gee
and I can't remember who all the
suspects were but I think it was attic
zidenna and somebody else and so that
was all throwaway because I'm like this
is not going to be the actual mystery
this is to prove out how we do things
and then when we were done I was like
well this isn't the story so we're not
going to keep any of this stuff so we
did keep certain assets that we
developed during that process
um
like pretty well figured out at that
point too it's such an iconic part of
the game stylistically stylistically
like yeah I mean and we we worked out
things man it was crazy like um
so
the First Act and the Abbey was actually
the very first place that got
um arted out
and a lot of the monastic characters
like illuminators were the first
character is done
and as time went on
um Hannah and Sujin who was our other uh
main artist on the project we really had
two main artists make all the art in the
game which is crazy wow
um but they kept increasing they just
got better and better and like their
kind of refinement within the style got
better and better and then there was a
point right near the end where
like they had done a revision to the
early scenes like a year ago but they
just never got around to checking them
in and it was crazy because they checked
them in and it was like wow like like I
got so used to seeing it the original
way that it looked and it the original
way looked really nice but their
revision to it was like holy crap this
will never stop blowing my mind yeah
it's it's it was really great so you
know they the thing is though Hannah is
just I can't say enough good things
about working with her um
she synthesized the kind of ideas that I
gave her into this cool art style
executed on it so well that right away
everyone was like awesome and then she
just kept improving on it and refining
it and um yeah I mean that's one of the
reasons why the the artists like the
standout thing when people are like oh
wow
it looks gorgeous yeah
um so obviously this game is about a
mystery this is a pretty loaded question
I guess how do you go about plotting out
a murder mystery that especially one
that's I don't know 15 hours ish or
however long pentiment ended up being to
to get through like how do you actually
plot out a murder mystery I don't even
know what that looks like is that like
are you still working on the writing in
an act structure is it a this person
dies and then what happens surrounding
this like what is the process of getting
that down
yeah I actually I I wonder I kind of
Wonder because I don't think I did a
great job plotting out the actual murder
mystery stuff like I feel like um actual
mystery writers maybe would look at this
and be like uh no
um and and part of that is uh is you
know um naivete on my part because I
haven't really written murder mysteries
before and that's why I asked like I
don't know how they do it and um and
there were also certain things that I I
chose to do that are against genre
convention I think in a lot of ways so
there is not a canonical killer
um there are suspects and you will
accuse one and they will die and or
you'll accuse multiple people and one of
them will die and at no point will we
say oh yeah it was actually this guy we
just don't do that
um there were other things that we chose
to not do which were in our vertical
slice this is a good example and our
vertical slice we went with the old
means mode of Alibi and so did they have
the means to do it did they have the
motive to do it and do they have an
alibi or not for their time and The
Alibi part of it not fun like because
all it does is exclude people and there
were so many nodes of dialogue and so
much complexity surrounding asking
people where they were
and that's not really the point because
in the structure of our story
you're learning about motive primarily
and means is a little bit in act one
it's not so much in act two but really
it's figuring out who wanted to kill
this person and why and what is their
character and because in the end we're
saying like what do you think and things
like Alibi just exclude people and
they're not interesting so we actually
literally don't deal with it at all we
just like never address it
um so you did originally try to we did
and it was and it was like holy [ __ ] I'm
writing so many nodes
and replies like exploring this topic
that is not interesting or fun and I
guess and it did just kind of be
Exposition in a way right that has to
just it is I was here doing this really
yeah well I talked to this guy in the da
da da and look like again that's a
staple of mysteries and there are games
where you know and that's why I don't
describe it typically as a as a murder
mystery game I described it as a
narrative Adventure that has a murderer
and things because I don't want people
to expect that there are like logical
yeah yeah and there are games that do
that and they do it very well and that's
the entire point and that's not the
point of pentiment so
um the mystery is more about there's a
there's a an overarching mystery that
goes across all three acts in all 25
years and that is more definitive and
hopefully more satisfying than to the to
the like mystery detective brain than
the murders that take place along the
way which are much more ambiguous and
they're
um kind of torturous because they ask
the player to decide who's going to die
and that's not a great feeling and
especially when you see how how
especially at the end of act one like
how the characters die is um
it's historically accurate and that's
not a that's not a that's not a nice
thing to see pause before saying it's
historically accurate yeah you're not
wrong it's technically historically
accurate so so it's not a good feeling
like I think that you know this is not
about capital punishment but like the
sense of satisfaction in a detective
game where you're like I got the killer
like I figured it out 100 everyone has a
parade and they clap you on the back and
you're like you're so smart and in
pentament they're like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] like
like why did you do that and you're like
man you can give reasons but it's like
God that just sucked
um because that's that's Justice in the
16th century baby yeah
um so yeah I would I would say you know
for the overarching conspiracy I did try
to lean more heavily on careful
foreshadowing and misdirection and I did
look at and watch a lot of uh mystery
films and Noir and um you know name of
the Rose was a huge the novel by Umberto
Echo was a huge inspiration for the game
overall and that is at its heart a
really engrossing murder mystery
um I don't think I do I do the mystery
as well as Umberto did but uh yeah there
were some of the Staples that we used
just to kind of build that build the
suspicion and then immediately misdirect
you so that you're kind of distracted or
we give you hints but then very
carefully put something in your way
mentally to kind of uh again like
disassociate you from kind of the the
truth of what's happening and it's it's
the same sort of tricks that happen in
in a lot of movies and and stories where
uh you want to keep teasing the player's
mind to make them or the reader's mind
to make them think about it but you
don't want to dwell on it too much
because you don't really want them to
figure out you want them to suspect but
not definitively solve at least that's
kind of how I look at it that's a that's
a lot to have to weigh up every scene I
feel like like that that it's not just
like true there's a mystery you're
actually trying to make sure that you're
you know string people along in a really
specific way that seems like a lot it is
it is um and like I said I don't in
retrospect think I did a great job I
think I did an okay job and it doesn't
come across that way oh thank you
um but yeah I I think at the heart of
pentiment though it's it's less about
that overarching mystery and it's more
about the relationships that Andreas has
with the community and I think if
there's anything that um the team did do
really well it was making the characters
feel very human and believable and uh
hopefully get the player to really care
about their lives and how they relate to
each other and the Mystery is kind of
like this this thing that is you know
again going above everything and pulling
you through the story I definitely think
um you know when you talk about this
game being about
figuring out motives it really is about
learning about different characters and
I think one thing that sentiments were
really good at is the minute that you
talk to someone the first sentence you
you get a very good picture of who they
are literally from their opening
sentence people are so distinct the
second you talk to them and I wanted to
ask like how many passes do characters
go through did you have a bio for
everybody and then kind of a writing
guide or a speech guide for each of them
because it's a lot of characters so how
do you it is a lot you know make sure
that you're really conveying exactly who
everybody is so quickly yeah um that's a
very good question uh so I knew very
early on that I really wanted a lot of
characters
um part of it is because I wanted to
represent a really wide section of
society I think that
although I love name of the Rose it is
about
um
monastics
and it's men it is male monks in one
specific place and there is some
International variety there but it's
monks and friars and that's about it and
there's very little there's like no
women basically in the entire story and
the pastry is is represented in kind of
this weird way and
so I was like no I want to show monks I
want to show nuns I want to show noble
men I want to show Crafts People and I I
remember you know I watched a lot of
stuff for reference and inspiration
there is a film based on a book about a
painting okay the called The Mill and
the cross which is about uh Peter
broigl's the elders uh the procession of
Calvary and it's a beautiful mannerist
painting and it is full of characters
and it's Christ crucified as in the
scene but it's almost like receding and
it's this enormous cast of characters
and in the film
um Peter bruegel says my painting needs
to be big enough to hold everything
everyone and part of that was to show
everyone from every part of society so
I'm like we're putting them all in and
and so I knew like we're gonna have a
huge cast and a lot of my initial work
was less about plot and more about
Community which is also later on I found
that's how Umberto Echo started the name
of the Roses he
um he literally just started writing
down a list of names of monks foreign
and he's like it's going to be a murder
mystery it's going to be in a monastery
and he just he was like names of monks
and where they're from and then he
worked from there and so I was like well
if we have a monastery it needs an Abbot
and it needs a prior and it needs a
Cantor and a sacristan and a sellerer
and then I was like and we have nuns and
they need a priorist and all these
people and then we have the town and
they need this and they need that and it
was for variety and contrast and for
every character
I wrote up something really brief about
their physicality I usually I picture
characters very quickly and very easily
and so I would write something very
brief about what they looked like and
then kind of their Vibe it was it was
never more than like three sentences
um and so there I have a document where
it's this very big dock where it has
them grouped by mostly by social class
or like you know if they live in the
Abbey or the or the um the town and what
their what their deal is and uh yeah so
that was the foundation of it and that
helped Hannah create art and she is so
good at taking those little tidbits and
interpreting them perfectly I remember
we have a character named uh Hedy hedvig
Hedwig Bauer in and she is the wife of
one of the farmers and I think my very
brief description of her was like wine
mom or something and um
Hannah drew a bunch of the peasant women
and without labeling them everyone was
like that's heavy she just captured it
so well and then what was great about
that is that reinforced we had that
picture I think it's for me anyway
having the physicality and the picture
of the character in my mind as I write
them
um is really helpful to me and that so
it's kind of this cycle where I have an
idea I write it out Hannah reinforces
that incredibly and then I'm like okay
now now I can take it and really write
this character
um and yeah I I tried to um and then
there were cases where you know like
someone would start writing and I'd be
like ah something's the tone is not
right there or you know and in cases we
would uh hand off characters because you
know we it's Logistics we can't all
write everything and there would be
times where I'd have to come back and
say like okay I think we kind of lost
the voice here this character doesn't
speak long sentences they're not stupid
but they don't speak long sentences they
don't use complex vocabulary three
they're pretty direct they're pretty
Gruff and here this character seems like
kind of nuanced kind of loquacious he's
using big words like loquacious and
um and so you know I'd say like step
back and kind of you know write that out
and uh you know like revise that I you
know and I would say like the content
what he is talking about is totally what
he should be talking about and the back
and forth is great but like the actual
lines themselves he just lost his voice
from the first act so with that in mind
then the writer would go back and revise
it and you know nine times out of ten it
was like cool you did it so again did
you have a speech guide for each
character did you have a you know they
speak in longer sentences they do or
don't use these phrases
not usually I would it was usually just
like a um a few words about their
personality and um like education maybe
yeah and then um you know thankfully it
was such a small writing team and there
was such a great deal of oversight
between us that it was really easy to
catch stuff like it was very rare that
someone was not that it didn't happen
but it was rare where a person would
write
for like a week and then I'd look and be
like oh God like like this is completely
wrong I completely lost all my
responsibility over this
um so yeah it was nice because uh and I
don't like to be I don't like to
encroach too much on the specifics
um the important thing is distinction
and character so it's not about like
this word or that word I mean rarely I
would say like maybe do a little tweak
here but for the most part I wanted
I had a very clear picture of this is
the character this is their personality
this is how they fit into this world
um but I left it to the writers to
really figure out the voice for that
character unless unless someone else had
already figured out the voice in which
case it's all of our responsibility to
pick up what we've been given and
continue with it out of curiosity do you
know how many characters you have
I believe
um and this is models I don't know if
this is actual speakers because not
every character speaks 157
so I would say of those probably 140
well that's a good question because
there are a lot of babies in there too
babies don't count they well a lot of
them grow up yeah
but no it's it's a it's a 140. um and
that's that's across all three acts and
yeah that they just run the gamut and
there's a there's a lot of characters so
do you think you could still name them
all
I mean like alphabetically no but like
but like do you think that you know
every character or would it be one you'd
be like absolutely I absolutely know
every character I mean I again I
designed every character so I was
curious if you could forget it I guess
like would is that everything way like
like any of them just exist in the game
rather than existing in your mind
forever no hmm
I think I probably expected that you
have to know it so intimately to execute
on directing a game yeah it's um yeah in
this case because the interconnectivity
of the community is so vital yeah you
know like if again because I think
visually if you ask me what are all the
characters in act one right now I could
think through every location in the game
and I could tell you every character
you're not gonna make me do that but I
believe but like but that's I I I have
to internalize that so much to
understand
the relationships between these
characters that that's I don't know
that's just part of doing it for sure I
guess yeah
um what do you think is the hardest
thing about making pentiment or I guess
your job in general making any of the
games you've made what do you think is
one of the most challenging things about
your job geez oh God it's a fun one yeah
I mean at this point sometimes it's
motivation like it can be easy to get
burned out
um I do think that after dead fire I was
pretty burned out
um because the game reviewed fairly well
but it did not sell well at all and
there's a lot of criticism and I
didn't so much take it personally as
like an insult but it made me go like
God should I even do this like and and
so I stopped directing for a while
because I'm like I don't even know what
to do
um and uh I'm glad I got to work on
pentiment because I really love
the subject matter I love the art I love
the I love art history and my father's a
sculptor I wanted to be an illustrator
I'm colorblind so that makes that hard
um yeah but my um so I was interested in
art history as a as a kid and growing up
and
um
some of my partners in the past have
been working artists so I've always
maintained this connection to Art and
history I have a history degree I just
love it so the chance to do this game
got me really passionate about doing it
and
my goals were really just to communicate
my love for this and draw other people
into the story and hopefully hopefully
some of that love would like wear off on
people and they would also become
interested in it but I really wanted to
make it very accessible and so many of
the games I've made are
hard
um yeah they're they're hard to get into
and they're really for a very specific
audience and they're really not for a
lot of people and
um I wanted this to be for a different
audience and it is not for it's one of
those things where I kind of feel like
um
in the reviews for pentament and I
understand why people say this so I'm
not saying I don't get it but they're
like this isn't for everyone
no [ __ ]
God of War is not for everyone Call of
Duty is not for everyone uh but there is
this expectation that normal games are
like real games and that's like four
like people like everyone but it's not
really
um and then ones that are kind of
unusual or weird those are the ones that
aren't for everyone but really everyone
has no difference for everything
everyone has a preference for everything
like Call of Duty one of the most
popular franchises on the planet and
that is okay
um and doesn't mean there's anything
wrong with it it's not bad
um but yeah like knowing knowing who
your audience is or trying to at least
understand who your audience is and
knowing that what you're making is going
to resonate with them and really get
them excited in the way that you get
excited about it I think it's really
important and I think when there are
disconnects there
um that can really be draining because
it's you know what am I doing wrong or
like why isn't this Landing I just is it
me is it like what is going on on so
with this game I think it was a much
like going back to the beginning there's
a much clearer sort of sense of
I like this type of game I like the idea
of this game I love it and then people
are like not my thing and I'm like cool
that's fine and that that feels a lot
better to me than when I try to make
something for an audience where they're
like
I made it for the audience and the
intended audience says I don't like this
I'm like oh yeah good so that's what
that's about yeah
yeah you don't want that
um so I guess like I know it's a really
difficult thing about being a director
at least a very important thing about
being a director is yeah you talk about
motivation if you're not motivated how's
your team supposed to stay motivated if
you don't believe that how's anyone else
supposed to believe in it I guess like a
big part of being a director from my
perspective and curious if you agree is
just making sure everyone's excited to
make the thing that they're making
absolutely you cannot I mean you can but
don't
um you can't drag people through making
a game yeah like you you can't
um
it's just you know taking people who
want to be creative and expressive and
and who got for the most part there are
people who are just kind of like yep
coding away like I don't care it's rare
um most people are in games because they
love games and they love making games
and they love seeing players get excited
about what what they made and
if people if yeah if you don't buy it or
if you do buy it but you can't
communicate it to the people and and get
them to share that and you can't share
with them because it has to be a
collaboration like even if they get it
and you're not letting them in to like
be part of the process oh that is not
good like they're they're like okay I
guess I'm coloring is hatred even though
I think it's [ __ ] stupid or like
whatever so you gotta believe in it you
gotta get people excited about it and
then you also have to take what they
give back to you you can't just be
looking for like a thumbs up you got to
listen to people
um and really take their contribution
into account because there's a lot of
cases on every game but you know on
pentiment there are a lot of cases where
I'm like this is the thing I want to do
and people are like uh
and I'm like well you just come on you
know like this is I think it's gonna do
this and and I would explain like this
is what I'm trying to accomplish with
this this is what I think is going to be
good for the audience for this
and so talking about that sometimes
there is a disagreement about like is
the audience gonna like this even if we
do it the way that you're saying or are
they not going to like it if you can
agree on that then maybe the execution
is the problem then you can talk about
the the kind of nitty-gritty and that's
usually where I step back and go like
okay so I thought about doing it this
way
art and animation or maybe it's art and
programming or whatever you got some
problems with it what's the deal
and they'll give some critiques and I'll
step back to the beginning I'll say like
okay so this is still the thing that I
want to do
so if you understand that you agree that
that's a good goal but this execution is
not it because of the reasons how can we
get back to this it doesn't have to be
the way that I said to do it because
you're the people doing it but I gotta
get this yeah unless you think that this
is not a good goal and that's usually
what I step back to because
when everyone gets lost in the specifics
of like we should do it this way very
often it's just individual opinions kind
of
like you're just arguing about the wrong
thing yeah and um and there were so many
times where I had an idea and I went for
it hard because I usually go for
everything hard and then you know people
on the team are like hold up not good
and I had to step back and they were
like okay and we'd go through that
process and then they'd say like how
about this and I go okay great awesome
do it and they do it and it was way
better uh we had this jar game it's an
act two where you're
um you're basically shaking jars of
herbs
and without getting into the details on
it it [ __ ] sucked like everyone just
hated it because it was it was really
confusing and like the instructions
weren't clear and the mechanics were
clumsy
and I came back and I'm like look the
whole thing here is I just want people
there's here are my goals it's fun to
shake jars so you you like it's just fun
to take your cursor and be like and then
you get the sound and each jar has a
different sound based on the thing in it
and it's fun to hear those noises and
that's all I really want
and so you can completely redo the
puzzle in a different way as long as we
keep those things because I don't want
to frustrate people that's not the point
I don't even want them to really be
challenged because none of our mini
games are really supposed to be
challenging
um
so with that in mind they're like you
know one of our programs Nikola he said
how about this and I was like great do
it yeah and he did it it went in
everyone's like that's a million times
better so you know again
um it doesn't really cost me anything in
the end we're not shipping ideas we're
not shipping documents we're shipping a
final game to share an experience and it
doesn't matter what I had in mind if it
doesn't translate into the game so I can
keep the vision
and be true to the vision while still
allowing the people on the team to push
back and say hold up go this way back up
we got to think about this some more and
it really does have to be yeah you got
to be enthusiastic about it you got to
be excited you got to get people on
board but then you also have to make
them collaborators in the process you
can't just hydraulically like press
everything down on the team and expect
them to just execute it like robots
thinking any one person knows better
than everyone else on the team
regardless of level of experience just
seems like a bad idea for making
something in general and yet maybe
maybe don't assume you know better than
everyone else and yeah
absolutely but yeah I imagine there are
some some people who've uh struggled to
learn that lesson for sure
um I was in one of the Gamescom previews
for this game and you said something
about
um
you know what this is talking about it
not being a game for everyone or the
idea of that you you mentioned that you
at the same time thought that it may
also be a game that people who didn't
play games might be interested in and I
was curious if you've seen any of that
like have you heard or seen stories
about people's parents playing or
people's parents watching
um and and how like what was that like
to to witness if you've seen any of that
yes uh it was great and it's it's been
great and it continues to be great
um you know obviously this is all
anecdotal but um I've seen a number of
people who are interested in history or
the art style really appeals to them or
they just like narrative games or story
games and they and they've heard that
it's not challenging it's not demanding
um I've seen a lot of people who say I
don't normally play games but I'm going
to check this out yeah that's awesome
and um some people who are like I'm
gonna play this with my mom or play this
with my dad or twitch stream of somebody
playing it with their dad yeah yeah I'd
be happy to send it to if you haven't
seen it it was really really cool
because I guess he was also um uh had a
masters in history of something yeah I
didn't see the stream I remember seeing
that that was going to happen lost in a
deluge of other things um but yeah and
like a lot of the people that I like I
went to school with in college I saw
them who I know are not Gamers and maybe
they're just being sympathetic or
whatever but they're like I'm gonna play
it um actually I know some of them are
actually playing it um and they're like
yeah I never play games but they're just
like this is such a cool presentation
and I love that it's very chill and cozy
and it's mostly reading and I've seen a
lot of people who really like to play
I'm so glad we got steam deck verified
um
a lot of people have been playing it on
Steam deck and uh they're like yeah this
is perfect it's just like a little
little visual storytelling game so uh
yeah I'm very glad
um obviously like I don't want to
exclude anyone but I do really think
that it will probably appeal to people
who normally aren't super they're not
into twitch games they're not into games
where there's lots of stats I mean
that's one of the reasons why there's
essentially no numbers in the game like
there's some stuff going on when you
make dialogue checks to persuade people
there's some math there but it's even
that is abstracted and that was another
example where I had numbers in there and
there would be this big list of like
plus three minus four and a few people
on the team are like wow that's a huge
bummer like yeah just see all that come
up in dialogue so we switch to the red
and blue Pips up and down
um so it's like I mean it's essentially
all still there but it's just presented
in a manner that is it's not as uh kind
of off-putting yeah I like that it still
has the obsidian DNA where that's
concerned yeah I'm not looking like
Fallout New Vegas without having a bunch
of numbers yeah so so yeah
um you know and I I that was a goal is I
did want it to be accessible to more
people
um and uh yeah at least so far I am
seeing anecdotally people just saying
yep I don't play games but I'm gonna
play this so did that change any
components of design like where you when
designing when you're literally thinking
about players who maybe haven't played
games before
yeah um a lot of the design of the
Mechanics for mini games especially
because those are all one-offs every
single one of our mini games is a unique
mini game and we're like these are not
supposed to be challenging these are
supposed to be very simple and they're
for immersion and Vibes so
um anytime we had a mini game where it
felt uh wow this is actually kind of
difficult
um we just pulled back on it because
it's just it's just not the point it had
to be engaging so for example we had the
stick breaking minigame with atelia I
don't know if you did that it's an
optional thing I did but Okay cool so
initially there was like literally
nothing to it it was like you just press
the buttons and it would snap and I was
like well that's not enough like that's
just not engaging so then she was like
they need to be a specific size and that
was it so we just you move your fingers
and you snap it and she'll be like raw
and she doesn't tell you she just says
you blew it or like that's fine and it
doesn't really matter it's just to get
the player thinking a little bit more
and you only break like five of them or
something thing but it's stuff like that
where it's like this is e
it's just supposed to give you context
within the story the spinning wool mini
game is extremely easy
um all that stuff we just tried to make
it really I think the volvell like prior
faring smell is probably the most
complicated
um or like the card game but even the
card game is actually really simple and
ultimately it's not a big deal if you
lose all your money it's fine
um so all that stuff was just like yeah
this is cozy time like people are not
sitting down at this to bang their head
against the wall they kind of just want
to Vibe out and and enjoy the story and
the most difficult thing mentally is
probably making the decisions about yeah
who to talk to and what what dialogue
choices to make and who to accuse me I
accidentally made plans with two people
and I was like oh which one should I
pick this is actually super stressed
about it I was like I accidentally lie
to somebody like it's definitely this
dress was in like the where I was going
to be and when and and who I was and
that's official and that's where I want
it to be I want the player to be engaged
in the story not tripped up on mini game
mechanics or numbers or things like that
um you know and if they look at you know
if they look at their choices you know
when you go into a check a dialogue
check like sister illuminata with the
book I don't know if you tried to keep
the book at the end of the uh I did keep
the book yeah yeah so you have to you
have to convince her and some ways are
easier than others
um but you know so we show you the
things but you're then thinking back to
the story moments because it's like you
sassed her you know like you said
something irreverent about the church
you demanded that books should all be
saved and you're like oh yeah I did that
yeah I said that and so it's still
keeping the mechanics within the context
of the story rather than kind of
abstracting them out into like speech 50
or you know like whatever
okay well I I could ask you a million
more questions but we only have one
minute left so uh all right my final
question is going to be
what is your favorite video game in
terms of writing
oh geez my favorite video game in terms
of writing
oh man he's a sucker punch yeah I really
like to leave you with an easy one
though yeah
um Disco Elysium is very that's mine up
there that's my number one
um Kentucky Route Zero is also way up
there and I gotta give my shout out to
uh
to Scott Benson for um uh Night in the
Woods because that was such a huge
inspiration it makes so much sense when
you say that it's yeah for pentament so
yeah I'd say those are those are
probably my my three big ones um there
are tons and tons of great I think
that's what's great about narrative
adventure games now is that we're seeing
a lot more just kind of writing that is
not to say that you can't have great
mechanical games with great stories in
them obviously God of War but um
but also you know like when it's sort of
like that's just the whole thing is just
the Vibes and just the story
um I think we're seeing a wider variety
of stories focusing on different people
and times and places smaller teams are
able to execute on this because there's
just less mechanical weight to carry and
I think that's really cool so
um especially you know and it's it's I
will say one other thing here at the end
which is some people have kind of
compared this to an indie game which I
think is kind of an insult to Indie
Games because they do all their stuff
with far far far fewer resources indie
games that came out this year
they do incredible things with very
small teams I had the benefit of doing
this for a long time and being part of a
a big Studio that's also part of a
humongous Corporation yeah so uh I owe a
huge debt to all the people that have
struggled and continue to struggle to
make Indie Games with Incredible writing
uh it's very inspiring to see like
literally directly inspiring to me to
see that stuff what a lovely end note uh
thank you so much for joining me Josh um
is there anything you want to give a
shout out to or where can people find
you
um I'm on Twitter je Sawyer and I have a
link tree there and whatever
um so you can go to my Tumblr or my
Instagram or my twitch which I don't
stream on very often uh but yeah I do
want to draw attention to you know I'm
doing all the interviews for the most
part for the game and I get that and
it's nice to get attention but
um you know 13 people made this game and
and more people contributed to it so
um they're all really integral to the
creation of the game when you play the
game please look at the credits and see
all the work that went into it because
they all did an incredible job awesome
well thank you so much to the entire
team for making pentiment I think it's
fantastic and thanks thank you so much
see you next time everybody
[Music]